in this video i'm going to discuss
another question from iit jam bt 2014
and this question is on nmr
and it says there are four compounds
given here as a b c d
and
we have to find which one of these
compounds have lowest delta value and
delta value means simply chemical shift
what is chemical shift chemical shift is
simply how our sample peak is deviated
from the reference peak
that means the tms reference peak
how much our sample peak is deviated
from the tms reference peak would give
us the measure for the delta value
now for this kind of question our
approach should be to find the
de-shielded condition around the
hydrogens so for these all four
compounds we would get a single peak in
the nmr proton nmr spectra
so if we analyze this first compound
there are two chlorines and two
hydrogens so two chlorine would pull the
electron density of
the cl bond towards itself so around
this hydrogen there would be our
de-shielded environment and this
de-shielded environment is very high
when there is a high de-shielded
environment
so as a rule of thumb we could remember
that when there is a de-shielded
environment
then the delta value that means the
chemical shift would be very high
because those peaks would be down filled
towards the tms reference now if we
analyze the second compound there are
three chlorine atoms so
the electron density is even more pulled
towards itself so around this hydrogen
there is a d shielded environment and
this is the highest distillated
environment among these four compounds
so here the delta
value that means the chemical shift
would be even higher
now if we come to the compound c and
compound d we would see both have one
chlorine atom and another have another
iodine atom and rest
both of them have three hydrogen atom
and now as iodine has less
electronegative
electronegativity
than a chlorine atom then these
electron density would be less pull
towards iodine than in chlorine
so this compound depicted in d
has the
lowest
delta value as it has less dc shielded
environment so for solving this question
we just have to understand that lesser
the disshielded condition
greater would be the delta value that
means the chemical shift and more the
de-shielded condition
more downfield would be the peak and
greater would be the chemical shift hope
this helped you
please like and subscribe thank you